what about mr. B now have you drawn a
line under him no more mr. B I you know
I doubt that he will reappear but um but
you never know you must never but you
know you must never say never again film
oh so you must never say never but I you
know you there does come a point when
you feel as though you've done most of
what you want to do with it
and because it's not based on language
because it's so physical mr. B it simply
it's popular everywhere yeah it is it
has what we might call a global outreach
so like our holidays of misery can you
go any go to many places where you're
not recognized and it's the yeah the
thing I find most tricky is when people
don't recognize you particular but half
recognize you you know that's where they
go feeling I wish that person wouldn't
stare at me sorry you know I'd rather
just you know hold the flag saying yes a
few years ago there was I was in a Land
Rover parts department near Peterborough
the kind of place you find me almost yes
and waiting for car parts and car parts
you guys hang around a lot because you
know to get a part of the guy has to go
half a mile to the back of the warehouse
and then come back again and he brings
it back and he says this is this is a
left-hand one oh you wanted to write on
one sorry I'll go it takes forever
anyway I was standing around with with a
group of guys and I could see this guy
doing that
and he came up to me after a while then
he said excuse me has anyone ever told
you that you are the absolute spittin
image of that mr. bean well actually I
am the actor who plays mr. bean and he
said bet you wish you were bizzarre
conversation in which the more I tried
to claim that I was a person whom he
thought I merely resembled less he
believed me but what was funny was how
was how close he thought I was he said
the resemblance have you ever thought of
doing any and you know look-alike work
like stag nights and had like you know
long as mr. bean
he said because you couldn't make an
absolute fortune and I could tell after
a while I had to bring the conversation
to a close because clean not only was he
not believing me but he was getting
quite annoyed I was pursuing this line I
am Rowan Atkinson when and clearly he
thought I was this total ass like mr.
bean goes around the country actually
claiming to be me
[Applause]
[Music]
you